من اجل مستقبل تركيا ووحدتها واستقرارها
ادعم الرئيس اردوغان هذا كان قرار سينان
اوغان المرشح السابق في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه ينظر الى كتلته
الانتخابيه على انها مرجحه لكفه احد
المرشحين في الجوله الثانيه وقد دعاها
للتصويت للرئيس اردوغان
اما شريكه السابق وداعمه في الجوله الاولى
زعيم حزب الظفر القومي المتطرف فقد اعلن
دعمه لكلجدارولو
اذا اردتم ان تبقى شوارعنا امنه واردتم
اعاده 13 مليون لاجئين الى بلادهم عليكم
ان تنتخبوا كمال كالجدار اوغلو صوت لصالح
سنان اوغان في الجوله الاولى نحو ثلاثه
ملايين ناخب مليونان منهم ينتمون الى
اقاليم مرمره ووسط الاناضول وبحر ايجه وهي
ثلاث من سبع مناطق جغرافيه تكون تركيا
وتضم مدنا تحتوي على معظم التيارات
السياسيه
ولذلك يقلل محللون سياسيون من تاثير اوغان
او اصدار على تصويت هذه الكتله الانتخابيه
ويقدرون انها مزيج من الغاضبين الرافدين
لكلا المرشحين
اردوغانو او انهم من مؤيدين مرشح المنسحب
محرم انجا الى جانب قومي متطرفين
تحتوي هذه الشريحه على اشكال مختلفه من
الفكر القومي والعلماني والاتاتركي لكن
يجمعهم التماهي مع التيار القومي ولو
بدرجات مختلفه ولذلك كلا الطرفين يحاولان
اللعب على الوتر القومي لجذبهم
[موسيقى]
وهكذا يحافظ اردوغان على ورقته الاقوى اذ
يدرك انه من الصعب ان يمنح القوميون
اصواتهم بشخص يحصل على دعم من حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي المتهم بقربه من حزب العمال
الكردستاني
وعدوا بالانسحاب من الشريط الامني لحمايه
تركيا من الارهابيين وسيطلقون سراح ارهابي
حزب العمال الكردستاني سيفعلون كل ما
يريده منهم الغرب اما نحن فنفعل ما تريده
تركيا
فينفي جلوسه مع اي تنظيم ارهابي بل ويتوعد
بالقضاء على الارهاب
وبعد ان كان يقدر اعداد اللاجئين بنحو
اربعه ملايين ويعد باعادتهم خلال عامين من
وصوله الى السلطه رفع عاليا من سقف خطته
اردوغان اقولها بوضوح انت لم تحمي حدود
وشرف هذا البلد اعلنها من هنا بمجرد وصوله
الى الحكم ساعيد كل اللاجئين الى بلادهم
بعد دعم سنانه
في
الجوله فانه وان ابدى تحالف الجمهور الثقه
في جذب الجزء الاكبر من ناخذه فانها
تعقيدات وتشابكات المكونات الفكريه
والسياسيه لهذه الشريحه تجعل من الصعب
التكاهنه بخيارات هؤلاء الناخبين في
الجزيره اسطنبول